We've all heard the advice. If you want to secure financial future, save for retirement, and start early, track your spending, don't spend more than you earn. But rules like these are far easier said than followed, especially if you're short on time, money, or both. Knowing this, some behavioral scientists are interested in learning more about how people make financial decisions and then using what they learn to help improve financial well-being, especially for people with low to moderate incomes. So why is it so hard to take the financial actions that we know we ought to be taking? What gets in the way? How do financial stress and anxiety affect us and our relationships? And how am I talking more openly about our finances help? What actions can you take now to set yourself on the best financial path? And what research-based actions could employers and institutions take to improve financial well-being for everyone? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
我们都听过这样的建议：如果你想保障未来的财务状况，就要为退休储蓄，尽早开始，记录你的开支，量入为出。但这些规则说起来容易做起来难，尤其是当你时间或金钱不足，甚至两者都缺的时候。鉴于此，一些行为科学家开始深入研究人们如何做出财务决策，并利用研究成果来改善人们的财务状况，特别是针对中低收入群体。那么，为什么我们明知应该采取某些财务行动，却难以付诸实践呢？是什么阻碍了我们？财务压力和焦虑如何影响我们及其人际关系？公开谈论财务状况又有何帮助？你现在可以采取哪些行动来走上最佳的财务道路？雇主和机构又可以采取哪些基于研究的行动来改善每个人的财务状况？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Wendy DeLerosa, an assistant professor at the Wharton School at the University of Pennsylvania. She focuses on using behavioral science to improve consumers' financial well-being. Her award-winning research has been published in many scientific journals and featured in the New York Times. The Wall Street Journal, CNN, and NPR, among other places. Dr. De La Rosa is also the co-creator and host of Ted's Your Money and Your Mind series, the co-founder of the Common Sense Lab, and a Forbes 30 under 30 financial honoree. Before joining Wharton, she helped start Google's first behavioral economics unit,
我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的助理教授温迪·德拉罗萨（Dr. Wendy De La Rosa）博士。她专注于利用行为科学来改善消费者的财务状况。她屡获殊荣的研究成果发表在许多科学期刊上，并被《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、CNN和NPR等媒体报道。德拉罗萨博士还是TED系列节目《你的金钱与你的思想》（Your Money and Your Mind）的联合创作者和主持人，Common Sense Lab的联合创始人，并入选了福布斯“30位30岁以下精英”财务榜单。在加入沃顿商学院之前，她曾帮助创立了谷歌首个行为经济学部门，
and she began her career as a private equity investor at Goldman Sachs. Dr. DeLarosa, thank you for joining me. Thank you for having me. It's a pleasure to be here. So I just mentioned that we all know these seemingly simple financial rules, but that knowing them doesn't mean that it's easy to put them into practice. Why is that? What gets in the way of people making the best financial steps for themselves? Oh, Kim, that's a million-dollar question. I think we kind of inherently know that answer because life is hard, because this is hard. one of the things that I tend to tell people is that we infantilize financial behaviors.
并曾在高盛集团担任私募股权投资人，开启了自己的职业生涯。德拉罗萨博士，感谢您接受我的采访。谢谢您的邀请，很高兴能来到这里。我刚才提到，我们都知道这些看似简单的财务规则，但知道并不意味着容易实践。这是为什么呢？是什么阻碍了人们为自己做出最佳的财务决策？哦，金，这可是个价值百万美元的问题。我认为我们内心深处其实知道答案，因为生活很艰难，因为这件事本身就很难。我常告诉人们的一点是，我们把财务行为“幼稚化”了。
You know, none of us think about saving the world from climate change by saying, let's get everybody in a room and teach them how to recycle. And that's how we're going to save the world. But for financial behaviors, for whatever reason, because especially in Western societies, we think about financial success. as a purely individualistic pursuit, we think, hey, let's get people in a room, teach them how to budget, and that will surely fix any financial anxieties. And so what we know from existing research is that that's just not the most effective tool. Because fundamentally, we all know what we need to do. The equation is not that hard. We all have subscriptions that we know we should cancel. we'll know that we should increase our retirement savings, right?
你知道，我们没人会想通过把大家召集到一个房间里教他们如何回收垃圾，来拯救气候变化，并认为这就是拯救世界的方法。但对于财务行为，无论出于什么原因——特别是在西方社会——我们认为财务成功纯粹是个人的追求。我们想：“嘿，把大家召集起来，教他们如何做预算，这肯定能解决所有的财务焦虑。”但根据现有研究，我们知道这并不是最有效的工具。因为从根本上讲，我们都知道自己需要做什么。这个公式并不难。我们都知道自己有哪些订阅服务应该取消，也知道应该增加退休储蓄，对吧？
The hard part is that right now is never the right time because right now I have to answer my work email because right now I have to go pick up my kids because right now I just don't have the time and also because I feel a level of shame around not being where I want to be. That's interesting that you talk about shame because a lot of financial advice columns and books have titles like top 10 financial mistakes to avoid. And I know you've said you don't like to frame people's financial behaviors as mistakes or bad decisions. Why do you feel that way? Well, I think it's because we have to be really honest about the world that we're in. Almost every company is getting smarter, more efficient, faster at getting you to part with your mind.
困难在于，当下永远不是合适的时机，因为现在我得回复工作邮件，因为现在我得去接孩子，因为现在我实在没时间，而且因为我对自己目前的处境感到羞愧。你谈到羞愧感很有意思，因为许多财务建议专栏和书籍的标题都是“要避免的十大财务错误”。我知道你曾说过，你不喜欢把人们的财务行为称为“错误”或“糟糕的决定”。为什么会有这种感觉？嗯，我认为这是因为我们必须诚实地面对我们所处的世界。几乎每一家公司都在变得更聪明、更高效、更快地让你掏出你的钱。
money. It's getting easier to spend not harder, right? The donut is getting tastier, not less tasty. And so we also have to recognize that our brains are not necessarily set up to think about the world and fundamentally understand compound interests. And so you have this world where you have a David versus not just one Goliath, but a David versus thousands of Goliath. And so what I want people to take away is that if you're struggling with your financial situation, you are not the only one. And it's not because you have this like personal failing. It's because it's actually really hard to do. Costs are rising. Wages are barely keeping up. And managing this complex world of finances where, you know, the average person in New York City sees thousands of
钱。花钱变得越来越容易，而不是越来越难，对吧？甜甜圈变得越来越诱人，而不是越来越难吃。因此，我们也必须认识到，我们的大脑并不一定天生就能理解这个世界，并从根本上理解复利。所以，你面对的是一个大卫不仅要对抗一个歌利亚，而是要对抗成千上万个歌利亚的世界。因此，我希望人们明白的是，如果你正在为财务状况挣扎，你并不孤单。这并不是因为你有什么个人失败，而是因为这确实很难。成本在上升，工资却几乎跟不上。在这个复杂的财务世界中，纽约市的普通人每天会看到成千上万个
ads and thousands of opportunities to spend money is just really difficult. And once we do this thing where we tend to internalize shame, that leads to more negative behavior because that leads us to ignore our problems, to not talk about our problems, to not want to find solutions to our financial well-being. And so I want to get rid of the shame that we feel about the fact that we're losing a battle against thousands of Goliaths. What about the role of financial education in helping to improve people's financial well-being? Are the programs that are taught in schools and workplaces helpful at all? Is there a way to do them better?
广告和成千上万个花钱的机会，这真的太难了。一旦我们倾向于将羞愧感内化，就会导致更多负面行为，因为这会让我们选择逃避问题、不谈论问题，也不愿寻找改善财务状况的方案。所以，我想消除我们因无法战胜成千上万个“歌利亚”而产生的羞愧感。那么，财务教育在改善人们财务状况方面起什么作用呢？学校和工作场所教授的课程真的有帮助吗？有没有更好的教学方式？
That's a great question. So I'll tell you from a study I conducted where I asked roughly about 1,000 households, what are some things that you could do in the next month to improve your financial security? over 94% of the households could list three or more things that they could do in the next month to improve their financial security. So fundamentally people know what they need to do. Like we talked about, it's just hard. And the research on the efficacy of financial education on financial behaviors is mixed at best, right? Why is that, well, you know, you can learn how to budget when you're in school, but ultimately your environment.
这是一个很好的问题。我曾进行过一项研究，询问了大约1000个家庭：在接下来的一个月里，你们可以做些什么来改善财务安全？超过94%的家庭能列出三件以上他们可以在下个月做的事情来改善财务安全。所以从根本上讲，人们知道自己需要做什么。正如我们所讨论的，只是执行起来很难。而关于财务教育对财务行为有效性的研究，结果充其量是好坏参半，对吧？为什么会这样呢？嗯，你知道，你在学校可以学习如何做预算，但最终，你的环境
is such a bigger predictor about how you spend your money than whatever class you took, you know, X many years ago. That's not to say that financial education doesn't play a role, but we have to recognize that it takes more than just financial education. It's about changing your environment and setting yourself up for success. What about people's basic mindsets? For example, I know you've done research looking at earning versus, is saving, and you found that people seem to be predisposed to favor earning more money as
对你如何花钱的预测能力，远比你多年前上的那门课要大得多。这并不是说财务教育没有作用，但我们必须认识到，仅靠财务教育是不够的。关键在于改变你的环境，并为自己的成功创造条件。那么人们的基本心态呢？例如，我知道你做过关于“赚钱”与“储蓄”的研究，你发现人们似乎更倾向于赚更多的钱，而不是
opposed to putting money away. Why do we think this way? Yeah. And so this is research by Isha Sharma where she has a paper aptly titled, A penny earned is not a penny save. And in her studies, one of the things that she focuses on is let's say you have two jobs. You can choose between them. One, you earn a little bit less money, but your expenses are a lot lower. You don't have to commute as far, so your transportation expenses are going to be lower. The other, you earn a little bit more, but your transportation expenses are going to be higher. So net net, they're the same. And what they found is that people are actively attracted to just earning more money,
存钱。为什么我们会有这种想法？是的，这是伊莎·夏尔马（Isha Sharma）的研究，她有一篇论文标题非常贴切，叫《赚到的一分钱不是存下的一分钱》（A penny earned is not a penny saved）。在她的研究中，她关注的一点是：假设你有两份工作可以选择。一份工资稍微低一点，但开销要低得多，你不需要通勤那么远，所以交通费用会更低。另一份工资稍微高一点，但交通费用会更高。所以净收益是一样的。研究发现，人们会被“赚更多钱”这一选项所吸引，
which makes sense because on the expense side, we feel like a lot of the expenses, expenses are more on our control, even though sometimes they're not, right? But we just feel a greater level of control. And so we have to recognize that the income piece of it all matters so much more than the expense side, right? Another way of saying this is someone's not going to get out of a financial hole by just cutting out their avocado toast, right? Like fundamentally we have to focus on what people naturally focus on, which is increasing their earnings. And then we can talk about creating a system where you can protect yourself against those Goliaths, meaning that you automatically split your paycheck from your employer so that X percentage of your paycheck goes to a savings account.
这很合理，因为在支出方面，我们觉得很多开支是在我们控制之内的，尽管有时并非如此，对吧？但我们只是觉得有更大的掌控感。因此，我们必须认识到，收入部分比支出部分重要得多，对吧？换句话说，一个人不可能仅仅通过不吃牛油果吐司就能摆脱财务困境，对吧？从根本上讲，我们必须关注人们自然关注的重点，即增加收入。然后，我们可以讨论建立一个系统来保护自己免受那些“歌利亚”的侵害，这意味着你可以自动将雇主发放的工资进行拆分，让工资的百分之几直接进入储蓄账户。
That's an environmental change. That's not us pretending that I can just teach you how to budget and have infinite willpower to never spend, right? It's about creating this environmental change so that we stop ourselves from having all this temptation and we create an environment that's setting us up for success. Let's talk for a minute about money and relationships. Finances are often one of the biggest stress points in people's marriage or long-term relationships. How should couples think and talk about finances and their decision-making?
这是一种环境改变。这不是假装我能教你如何做预算，并让你拥有无限的意志力去克制消费，对吧？这是关于创造这种环境改变，让我们不再面对所有诱惑，并创造一个为我们成功铺平道路的环境。让我们花点时间谈谈金钱与人际关系。财务往往是夫妻或长期伴侣关系中最大的压力点之一。伴侣应该如何思考和谈论财务及其决策？
What are the questions that you should be asking your partner to make sure that you're on the same page financially? Oh, this is such an important point because about 40% of couples don't even talk about their finances before they get married. And we know that financial disagreements tends to be one of the leading causes for divorce. It's just so difficult. And I often get some people saying, well, you know what, if we just keep our finances separate, we don't have to talk about it, right? They earn their money, right? They spend their money how they want. I earn my money and I spend my money how I want. And I'm not here to tell people how to split their money, but I will say, well, you think that that doesn't impact you. It does because under, like, U.S. law, if you get married, your spouse's debt is your debt unless you have a pre-up, right? And so you fundamentally have to talk about and discuss your, your finances. One of the things that also happens is that there tends to be one partner that takes on the bulk of the financial management. And there tends to be another partner
你应该问伴侣什么问题，以确保你们在财务上达成共识？哦，这一点非常重要，因为大约40%的伴侣在结婚前甚至不谈论财务问题。我们知道，财务分歧往往是导致离婚的主要原因之一。这真的太难了。我经常听到有人说：“好吧，如果我们保持财务独立，就不必谈论它了，对吧？”他们赚他们的钱，想怎么花就怎么花；我赚我的钱，想怎么花就怎么花。我不是来告诉人们如何分配金钱的，但我会说，你以为这不会影响你吗？会的，因为根据美国法律，如果你结婚了，除非有婚前协议，否则你配偶的债务就是你的债务，对吧？所以你必须从根本上谈论和讨论你们的财务状况。另一个常见的情况是，往往有一方承担了大部分的财务管理工作，而另一方
that sort of relinquishes or abdicates the financial management responsibilities. And in a study by Adrian Ward and John Lynch, what they found is that this is actually really problematic. it because as couples go through their life, that partner that takes on all their financial management skills, they become more and more adept over time. But that partner that has relinquished their control, it's not that they stay the same. They become less and less adept at managing their finances over time. And why is this problematic? Well, God forbid you break up or you get divorce. Now that partner that has relinquished all of that responsibility is in a worse financial situation because they have less financial management skills than they had when they started the
则放弃或推卸了财务管理责任。在阿德里安·沃德（Adrian Ward）和约翰·林奇（John Lynch）的一项研究中，他们发现这实际上非常成问题。因为随着夫妻生活的发展，那个承担所有财务管理职责的伴侣会随着时间的推移变得越来越熟练。但那个放弃控制权的伴侣，并不是保持原样，而是随着时间的推移，在管理财务方面变得越来越不熟练。为什么这很成问题？好吧，如果万一你们分手或离婚了，那个放弃了所有责任的伴侣现在的财务状况会更糟，因为他们拥有的财务管理技能比刚开始
relationship. And a lot of the time, sadly, that ends up being in heteronormative couples, that ends up being the women. And of course, we've all heard the stories about the couple gets divorced and the woman discovers that her ex has drained the bank accounts, that there's no money left because she paid no attention, right? She left it all up to him. So I can see how that's a big problem in a lot of relationships. But, you know, the other thing is that we've learned that talking about money is impolite, right? And you're a big proponent of talking openly and honestly about money, not just with your partners, but with your friends and family. So why is it important to have those conversations? What should we be talking about that we're not?
这段关系时还要少。可悲的是，在异性恋伴侣中，这种情况往往发生在女性身上。当然，我们都听说过这样的故事：夫妻离婚了，妻子发现前夫已经掏空了银行账户，因为她从不关注财务，对吧？她把一切都留给了他。所以我明白这在许多关系中是一个大问题。但是，另一件事是，我们从小被教导谈论金钱是不礼貌的，对吧？而你是公开、诚实地谈论金钱的坚定支持者，不仅与伴侣，还与朋友和家人。那么，为什么进行这些对话很重要？我们应该谈论哪些我们目前没有谈论的话题？
Well, it's so important because we know from research that you can get so many better. benefits from talking about your finances with other people. For example, when we think about our relationship with our friends, we're much more likely to know our friends' dating history and all the baggage that comes with that than about their retirement accounts or whether or not they are in debt. And when we think about our relationships with our friends and what we know about their financial situation, we tend to know every time they spend and or get into debt. We know when they buy a new car or they buy a new watch. We know effectively when they go on a large or lavish trip.
嗯，这非常重要，因为研究表明，与他人谈论财务状况可以让你获得更多好处。例如，当我们想到与朋友的关系时，我们更可能了解朋友的恋爱史以及随之而来的所有包袱，而不是他们的退休账户，或者他们是否负债。当我们想到与朋友的关系以及我们对他们财务状况的了解时，我们往往知道他们每次花钱或负债的情况。我们知道他们什么时候买了新车或新手表。我们实际上知道他们什么时候去进行了一次大型或奢华的旅行。
But we don't really know whether or not they're saving for retirement. For whatever reason, that becomes taboo. And if we're friends, if we're genuinely friends, I care about your well-being and you care about my well-being. Why not talk about one of the most important parts and predictors of our general well-being, which is our financial security? I might learn something from you, you might learn something from me. And this is not hypothetical.
但我们并不真正知道他们是否在为退休储蓄。无论出于什么原因，这成了禁忌。如果我们是朋友，如果我们是真正的朋友，我关心你的幸福，你也关心我的幸福，为什么不谈论我们整体幸福感最重要的部分和预测指标之一，即我们的财务安全呢？我可能会从你那里学到东西，你可能会从我这里学到东西。这并非假设。
Our friends can also hold us accountable. One of the lovely studies that I love shows that when friends come together and share their savings goals out loud and hold each other accountable week after week, people end up saving more. So our friends are here to just help us in all sorts of domains, including our financial domain. The other piece I would say is you don't know what you don't know, especially if you don't talk about money. How will you ever know if you're underpaid if you don't ever ask other people what they make? Now, that's something, though, that tends to be highly discouraged in workplaces, people sharing with each other who makes how much money. I mean, how do we overcome that when your employer is telling you, don't talk about this. Don't tell the person in the next cubicle how much money you're making because maybe she's making 10,000.
我们的朋友也可以监督我们。我最喜欢的一项研究表明，当朋友们聚在一起大声分享他们的储蓄目标并每周互相监督时，人们最终会存下更多的钱。所以我们的朋友可以在各个领域帮助我们，包括财务领域。我想说的另一点是，你不知道你所不知道的，特别是如果你不谈论金钱的话。如果你从不问别人赚多少钱，你怎么知道自己是否被低估了呢？不过，在工作场所，人们分享彼此的薪资通常是被高度禁止的。我的意思是，当雇主告诉你“不要谈论这个，不要告诉隔壁工位的人你赚多少钱，因为也许她比你多赚一万美元，但做的是同样的工作”时，我们该如何克服这一点？当你发现这一点时，你会怎么做？嗯，我认为我们必须思考这到底对谁有利？沉默和缺乏透明度往往对雇主有利，因为他们可以考虑以不同的方式支付薪酬，特别是对于做同样工作的人，对吧？所以一旦你意识到沉默到底对谁有利，你就可以赋予自己力量，说：“好吧，这对我没好处。”
in a year more than you are and doing the same job? What will you do when you find that out? Well, I think we have to think about who does that help? Silence and lack of transparency tends to help the employer because they can think about different ways in which to pay people differently, especially people who are doing the same job, right? And so once you recognize, like, who is the silence actually helping, then you can empower yourself and say, well, it's not helping me. Right? It's not helping me. And, you know, people think about wages as sort of a zero-sum game. A lot of the times, right, if I learn that I'm getting underpaid, I can now gather the information and come to my employer with a better sense of skills of saying, hey, this is the skill so that I bring
对吧？这对我没好处。而且，人们往往把工资看作是一种“零和博弈”。很多时候，如果我发现自己被低估了，我现在可以收集信息，并带着更好的技能感去找雇主说：“嘿，这是我带来的技能，这是我知道我应得的价值。”但假设情况反过来，我是那个与同事相比被“高估”的人。如果我的同事增加了收入，对我一点伤害都没有。事实上，现在基准线重置了，这反而为我创造了赚更多钱的机会。
to the table and this is what I know that I'm worth. But let's say it's the other way around where I'm the person that's quote unquote overpaid compared to my colleague. It doesn't hurt me at all if my colleague increases their income. In fact, it now creates an opportunity for me to make more money right now that the baseline has reset. And so I want people to think about this as it's never really a zero. sum game and thinking about finances as a zero-sum game can sometimes lead to really problematic
所以我希望人们把这看作永远不是真正的零和博弈。把财务看作零和博弈有时会导致非常成问题的竞争行为，而这本是不必要的。我想问一下你的家庭背景。你小时候会公开讨论金钱吗？你是如何对研究人们如何处理和管理金钱产生兴趣的？我逃避这个话题太久了。这是我最后想做的事情。所以我给你讲讲我的背景。我出生在多米尼加共和国。像许多家庭一样，我的家人从多米尼加移民到布朗克斯，只是为了更好的财务生活。我喜欢开玩笑说，缺钱是餐桌上的第六个人。这始终是谈话的主题。我们家里非常清楚我们没有多少资源。
competitive behaviors in a way that it doesn't have to be. I want to ask about your family background. Was money discussed openly when you were a kid? How did you get interested in studying how people relate to and manage their money? I ran away from this topic for so long. long. This is the last thing I thought I was going to be doing. So I'll give you a little bit of my background. I was born in the Dominican Republic. My family immigrated from the Dominican Republic to the Bronx, like many families in hopes of just a better financial life. And the lack of money, I like to joke and say, was the sixth person at the dinner table. It was constantly a topic of conversation. We were very much aware in my family that we did not have a lot of resources.
所以我当时自告奋勇地想：我怎样才能在尽可能短的时间内赚尽可能多的钱？我有点回避我的历史。我不想告诉别人我出身贫寒。我假装了很长一段时间，扮演着不是我的人。直到我意识到这给我的人生带来了多大的负担、压力和羞愧，以及它在某种程度上滋养了多少负面情绪，每天戴着这个面具是多么令人筋疲力尽，我才开始作为一个真正的人蓬勃发展。
And so I took it upon myself at that time to think about, well, how can I try to earn as much as possible in a short time period as possible? And I sort of shied away from my history. I didn't want to tell people that I came from little memes. I pretended for a long time to be somebody that I wasn't. And it wasn't until I realized how much of a burden and weight and shame, how much negativity that was sort of feeding into my life, how exhausting it was to put on this mask every day, that I started to flourish as a person.
因为那时我可以真实地表达自己，说：“嘿，实际上，这是我所有的担忧。你是怎么处理这个问题的？”突然之间，人们可以用不同的方式与我建立联系。他们给了我建议，给了我更多的机会，因为他们知道我所处的道路。再一次，正是通过谈论金钱，并坦诚地面对我财务不安全的历史，才让人们对我产生了更大的兴趣，并给了我更多的机会。
Because then I could be authentic. and say, hey, actually, here are all the concerns that I have. How have you dealt with this? And now all of a sudden, people could connect with me in a different way. They gave me tips. They gave me more opportunities because they knew the path that I was on. And it was, again, by talking about money and being open and frank about my history of, you know, financial insecurity, that it led people to become much more interested in me and give me more opportunity.
但我得告诉你，因为我花了很多年逃避那段历史，这是我最后想做的事情。而现在，这是我唯一想做的事情。我正在过着我梦想的生活。我正在做的事情正在帮助像我家人那样的人。说到这里，我知道你一直对金钱问题如何影响孩子很感兴趣，特别是移民的孩子，当他们不得不扮演父母的角色并帮助家庭理财时。当你观察这种情况时，你发现了什么？首先我们必须认识到，贫困是一种创伤。很多时候，我们对在贫困中长大的孩子脱敏了。我们认为他们更有韧性，我们认为他们
But I will tell you, because I spent so many years running away from that history, this is the last thing that I thought I would be doing. And now it's the only thing that I wish to be doing. I'm living my dream life. I'm doing things that I are helping people like my family. Speaking of which, I know you've been interested in how money issues affect kids, particularly the children of immigrants, when they have to step into that parental. role and help with family finances. What do you find when you look at that situation? So the first thing we have to recognize is that poverty is trauma. And a lot of times we desensitize children who grew up in poverty. We think that they're more resilient. We think that they're
更能抵抗痛苦。这是埃尔德·沙菲尔（Eldar Shafir）等人的研究成果。但事实并非如此。所以我们必须认识到贫困是一种创伤。现在，如果你再加上移民家庭的因素，家庭正在学习一门新语言，我将从我自己的经历中谈起。我不得不成为主要的翻译，我觉得我妈妈已经尽力了，但让一个孩子处于那种位置去翻译账单，去处理讨债人和父母之间的谈判，这真的很难。它围绕金钱创造了一种独特的心理。
more resistant to pain. This is research from Elder Shafir and others. And that's not the case. So we have to recognize that poverty is trauma. Now, if you add into that mix, sort of an immigrant family where the family is learning a new language, I'll all speak from my own experience. I had to become the primary translator in a way that I think, you know, my parent, my mom was doing the best she could. but it is hard for a child to be put in that position to translate bills, to be in the middle of negotiations between, you know, ex-bill collector and your parent. And it creates a unique mentality around money.
现在，我们所不知道的是——这也是我希望继续研究的——人们从那种情况中走出来，可能会对金钱产生一种挥霍的心态，说：“你知道吗，我小时候没钱。所以一旦我有钱，我就要尽可能多地花掉它，去得到我错过的东西。”而另一些人从那种情况中走出来，却变得吝啬，说：“你知道吗，我小时候没钱。所以现在无论我得到什么资源，我都要囤积起来，即使我知道花钱会给我带来快乐，我也很难花出去。”是什么决定了这一点呢，金？我们仍然不知道。但我们知道，这两种结果，
Now, what we don't know, and this is research that I'm hoping to continue, is people come from that situation and they can either have a spent, thrift mentality towards money, saying, you know what, I didn't have many growing up. So I'm going to, as soon as I get money, I'm going to use it and spend it as much as possible to get what I laughed. And other people come out of that situation and they become tightwads to say, you know, what, I didn't have money growing up. And so now anytime I receive resources, I'm going to hoard it and I have a very hard time spending it, even if I know that it's going to bring me joy. And what determines that king? We still don't know that. But we know that both of those outcomes, right,
很可能都源于缺乏财务安全感。好吧，让我们稍微转换一下话题，谈谈一些实用的建议。我想知道，在明知我们都生活在一个对我们不利的系统中的情况下，人们为了实现财务成功，最重要的事情是什么？这是一个价值百万美元的问题。对吧。所以我会这样说：每个人的财务状况都不同，但你比任何人都更了解自己的财务状况。所以你可能是一个会说“天哪，我真的需要打电话给信用卡公司，更改我的付款日期，以便它最符合我的发薪时间”的人。或者你可能是一个听这个播客的人，对自己说：“天哪，我真的需要坐下来，终于为我的孩子开一个大学储蓄账户了。这已经在我的待办事项里很久了。”再次强调，人们从根本上知道自己缺少什么，无论是开一个储蓄账户，进入那个非常笨拙的工作门户网站，终于增加你的退休缴款以获得雇主匹配。或者也许是，“你知道吗，我只需要坐下来弄清楚我是怎么花钱的。”所有这些都需要时间。
are very likely coming from a lack of financial security. Well, let's shift the topic a little bit and talk about some practical advice, which is, I want to know what's the most important things that people can do to set themselves up for financial success, knowing that we're all living in a system that is stacked against us. The million-dollar question. right. So here's what I would say. Everybody's financial situation is different, but you know your financial situation better than anybody else could. So you could be a person that says, man, I really need to call up my credit card company and change my payment date so that it best aligns with how I get paid. Or you could be a person listening to this podcast and say to yourself, man, I really need to sit down and finally open up a college savings account from my kid. Like it's been on my to do for a long time. Again, people fundamentally know what they're lacking, whether that's opening up a savings account, going into your work portal that's so clunky and finally increasing your retirement contribution so that you get your employer match. Or maybe that's, you know what, I just need to sit down and figure out how I'm spending my money. All of that takes time.
当事情需要时间时，你必须足够爱自己，把你自己放在优先位置。我告诉人们，你现在能做的改善财务安全的第一件事，就是把时间安排在日程表上，给自己放一个“财务健康日”。当你生病时，你会请病假；当你需要心理放松时，你会请心理健康假。如果你需要整理你的财务状况，就请一个“财务健康日”。花点时间，现在就把它写在你的日程表上，说：“这是我想要完成的三件事。”你知道吗？我终于要分配时间去取消那些我不想要的订阅了，或者我终于要分配时间去立一份遗嘱了。所有这些我们知道需要做的事情，
And when things take time, you have to love yourself enough to prioritize. you. And what I tell people is the number one thing that you could do to improve your financial security right now is to put time on the calendar and take a financial health day. When you're sick, you take a sick day. When you need a mental break, you take a mental health day. If you need to get your financial house in order, take a financial health day. Take the time, put it on your calendar right now and say, these are the three things that I want to accomplish. You know what? I'm finally going to allocate the time to cut those subscriptions that I don't want, or I'm finally going to allocate the time to set up a will. All of these things that we know we need to do,
它们都需要时间，并且要求我们足够爱自己，去请一个财务健康日。我知道你研究的一个领域是人们获得报酬的频率，以及这如何影响他们的消费和储蓄。你发现了什么？这是我和南加州大学的斯蒂芬·塔利（Steph Tully）共同研究的领域。为了让大家了解背景，现在出现了大量“提前工资获取”应用程序，这意味着如果你每周五发工资，你不必等到周五才能拿到钱。你可以在周一、周二或周三就拿到钱。如果你只是从表面上看，这对消费者来说似乎是一个巨大的胜利，因为我为什么要给我的雇主提供零利率贷款呢？
they take time and they require us to love ourselves enough to take a financial health day. I know one area that you've been studying is the frequency with which people, get paid, how that can affect how they spend and save. What have you found? So this is an area of research that I have with Steph Tully at USC. And to give everybody context, there's been this proliferation of early wage access apps, meaning that if you get paid every Friday, you don't have to wait until Friday to get paid. You can get paid on a Monday or Tuesday or Wednesday. And if you just think about it on a shallow basis, that seems like a great win for consumers because why should I give a zero percent interest loan to my employer?
对吧？如果我周一工作，我应该能在周一拿到工资。这确实是一个合理的论点。然而，我总是关注消费者的心理如何变化，以及他们的行为如何随环境而变化。我们发现，人们获得报酬的频率越高，他们最终花的钱就越多，特别是在餐饮等可自由支配的项目上。这是为什么呢？这是因为即使你和我每两周都赚2000美元，如果你获得报酬的频率更高，你会觉得你稍微富有了一点。因为你知道钱
Right? If I got paid on, if I work on Monday, I should be able to get paid on Monday. And there is a lot of, you know, that is a valid argument. However, I am always focused on how does the psychology of a consumer change and how do their behavior change as a function of the environment. And what we find is that the more frequently people get paid, the more they end up spending, especially on discretionary items like eating out. And why is that? It's because even though you and I both make $2,000 every two weeks, if you get paid more frequently, you feel like you're a little bit richer. Because you know money's
明天就会进来，所以你觉得自己在主观上更富有了。而那种感觉自己稍微富有了一点的感觉会让你花更多的钱。这在很多方面都是有问题的。我们发现的一个现象是，更高的支付频率也与更高的银行费用和更高的透支可能性相关。所以我希望人们真正思考的是，对流动性的需求是至关重要的，但就像生活中任何值得研究的事情一样，我们必须为它设定界限。太多的流动性可能是一件坏事，流动性不足也可能是一件坏事。比如问问自己，我真的需要提前获取工资吗？特别是考虑到许多这些提前工资获取应用程序会向你收取费用。当你计算一下数学，
coming in tomorrow and so that you feel like you're subjectively wealthier. And that feeling of feeling a little bit richer makes you spend more. And that's problematic for a number of different reasons. But one of the things that we find is that higher payment frequency is also associated with higher bank fees and higher likelihood of overdrafting. And so I want people to really think about there is a critical need for access to liquidity, but just like anything that's worth studying in life, right, that we have to set boundaries on it. And so too much liquidity can be a bad thing. Not enough liquidity can be a bad thing. Like think to yourself, do I really need to access my pay early? Especially because a lot of these early wage access apps charge you fees. And when you work out the math,
它最终和发薪日贷款一样糟糕。2.99美元看起来不多，或者3.99美元看起来也不多。但每天3.99美元。现在，你又在一点一点地蚕食你辛苦赚来的钱了。那么向无现金社会的转变呢？我的意思是，我们很多人口袋里再也没有现金了，因为我们不需要。我们靠信用卡生活。这如何影响人们今天的消费和储蓄？
it ends up being just as bad as a payday loan. And $2.99 doesn't seem that bad or $3.99 doesn't seem that bad. $3.99 every single day. Now, again, you're just eating away at your hard-earned money. What about the movement toward a cashless society? I mean, a lot of us never have any money in our pockets anymore because we don't need to. we live off of credit cards. How is that affecting how people spend and save today?
嗯，我想说的第一件事是，我们只是在加剧不平等。有很大一部分人口没有银行账户或银行服务不足，这意味着很大一部分人口被迫进入无现金社会。在美国，要开设银行账户，你需要一个地址。从根本上讲，对吧？我们没有考虑到这一点。
Well, the first thing I want to say is that, you know, we're just exacerbating inequality. There is a large swath of the population that's unbanked or underbanked, meaning that there's a large part of the population that is being forced into a cashless society. In order to get a bank account in the U.S., you need an address. Like fundamentally, right? And we don't think about that.
但随着无家可归现象的增加，在美国开设银行账户，你需要社会安全号码或税号。我们有数百万人依赖现金经济。所以当餐馆说“不，我们只接受借记卡”时，当餐馆或企业说“不，我们只接受Apple Pay”时，这是一种加剧不平等并创造“有产者”和“无产者”之间双层体系的形式。
But with houselessness being on the rise, in order to get a bank account in the U.S., you need a social security number or a tax ID number. We have millions of people who are relying on the cash economy. And so when you have restaurants that say, no, we only accept debit cards. When you have restaurants or businesses that say, no, we only accept, you know, Apple Pay, it's a form of exacerbating inequality and creating this two-tier system between the halves and the half-nots.
现在，话虽如此，当你不再需要拿出信用卡，而只是“滴”一下手机时，人们会发生什么呢？嗯，我们与研究人员所说的“支付痛苦”拉开了距离，这意味着如果你只是刷手机，感觉并不像真的在浪费钱。比如当你在星巴克时，对吧？当我们因为感觉不到钱在流失，因为感觉不到我们在花钱，而将自己与“支付痛苦”剥离时，这就会增加我们花钱的可能性。
Now, putting that, you know, having said that, what then happens to people when you're constantly having to not to not just take out your credit card anymore? Right, now it's a tap. Well, we distance ourselves from what researchers call the pain of pain, meaning it doesn't feel like you're really wasting any money if you just tap your phone. If when you're at Starbucks, right? And when we disassociate ourselves from the pain of pain because we don't viscerally see the money leaving, because it doesn't feel like we're spending anything, then it increases our likelihood of spending.
这是我们必须认识到的。回到我们谈话的开头，一切都在变得……企业在让我们更快地花钱方面变得越来越老练。刚才你谈到我们如何给雇主提供0%利率的贷款。这让我想起几年前，我有一位税务会计师，他每年元旦都在做自己的所得税申报，因为他想尽快拿到退税。
And that's something that we have to recognize. Again, going back to the beginning of our conversation, everything is getting, businesses are getting more sophisticated at getting us to spend our money faster. A minute ago, you talked about how we give our employers a 0% interest loan. And that got me thinking about years ago, I had a tax accountant who spent every New Year's day doing his own income taxes because he wanted to get his refund as soon as possible.
然而我们知道，大多数人，即使是那些会得到退税的人，也会等到最后一刻才去报税。你曾主张将报税截止日期从4月15日移至3月15日。你为什么认为这会有帮助？我们看到的是一种U型模式。我们看到像那位税务会计师一样的数百万人，当他们预期会有大额退税时，他们会尽可能快地等待W-2表格的到来，
And yet we know most people, even those who are going to get refunds, wait until the last minute to do their taxes. You've advocated for moving tax day from April 15th to March 15th. Why do you think that would help? So what we see is a U-shaped pattern. So we see millions of people like her tax accountant who, when they expect a large tax refund, they're waiting for that W-2 to come as quickly as possible,
特别是那些指望这笔钱的人，对吧？我们发现，许多获得大额退税的人，特别是通过劳动所得税抵免获得退税的人，他们在心理上已经把这笔钱花了好几次了。对吧？“我要用这笔钱还债。我还要用这笔钱储蓄。我还要用这笔钱买某某东西。”
especially people who are counting on that money, right? What we find is that a lot of the people who get large refunds, especially through the earned income tax credit, they have mentally spent that money a couple times over. Right? I'm going to use this money to pay down debt. I'm also going to use this money to save. I'm also going to use this money to buy XYZ.
然后当你把它们加起来时，你已经分配了超过100%的金额。这不是任何人的错，这只是我们大脑运作的方式。然后转到U型曲线的另一端，你会发现有些人是受截止日期驱动的。比如，如果你回想大学时代，你写大学论文时最努力的时候，可能就是截止日期的前一天。对吧？我会举手承认那个人就是我，对吧？我不会让你处于尴尬境地。是一样的。所以，为什么要拖延这种持续的心理负担，说“我知道我需要做这个，我知道我需要做这个，我知道我需要做这个”呢？让我们尽快把钱还给人们。对吧？这部分在于认识到人们对截止日期的反应，并提前截止日期，对吧？
and then when you add it up, right, you're spent, you've allocated more than 100% of it. That's, you know, that's not a fault of anybody. That's just how our minds work. I then going to the other part of that U-shaped curve is that you have people who are motivated by deadlines. Like, if you think about your college days, you probably didn't work. The hardest you worked on a college essay was the day before it was due. Right. And I will put myself, I will raise my hand and say that that was me, right? I won't put you on the hot seat. It's the same. And so why drag out this intense period of, you know, constant mental burden of saying, I know I need to do this, I know I need to do this, I know I need to do this. Let's just get the money back to people's hands as quickly as possible. Right. And part of that is recognizing how people react. to deadlines and moving that up, right?
让我们……在美国，现在报税如此繁琐是没有理由的。我们生活在一个我们的机构——我会说我们最重要的机构，即国税局（IRS），那个负责运营我们国家、支付、征收并最终分配我们资金的机构——正在使用甚至在公开市场上都买不到的软件。它就是这么老旧。对吧。
Let's, there's no reason, right? Why it's so cumbersome in the U.S. to file our taxes right now. We are living in a world where our agency, like I would argue our most important agency, the IRS, the agency that's responsible for just running our country, right? Paying, collecting, and ultimately, you know, dispersing our funds. is operating on software that is not even available in the open market. That's how old it is. Right.
这太疯狂了。所以我们必须再次考虑改变环境，让每个人都更容易，而不仅仅是低收入人群。报税不应该这么难。我们不应该等上好几个月才能拿到退税，我们应该认识到我们可以利用心理学，利用那种从即将到来的截止日期中获得的动力来为我们服务。所以我必须问，有没有什么金钱话题或问题是你认为完全是禁忌的？
That is crazy. And so we have to think about, again, changing the environment so that it's easier for everybody, not just the lower income people. It shouldn't be this difficult to file our taxes. We shouldn't have to wait months and months and months to get our refunds back. and we should recognize that we can use psychology, right? That sort of boost that we get from a pending deadline to our benefit. So I have to ask, are there any money topics or questions that you think are completely taboo?
哦，天哪。完全是。我明白了。我知道。我有点在想，你知道吗，我会……这是我要说的。每一个重大的人生时刻，无论是离婚、结婚，还是去看心理健康专家，金钱总是背景。你必须以某种方式支付费用。
Oh, man. Completely. I got you. I know. I'm sort of thinking, you know what, I'm going to. here's what I'll say. Every major life moment, whether it's getting divorce, getting married, going to see a mental health professional, money is always in the background. You have to pay for it somehow.
我们认为在某种程度上是可耻的每一种癖好，无论是性癖好还是成瘾，在某种程度上都与金钱有关，对吧？如果我对某种药物上瘾，我仍然必须为它付费。如果我对某种癖好上瘾，人们也会以某种方式为它付费。所以那些自然令人羞耻的，或者人们感到羞耻的事情——无论他们是否应该感到羞耻——我认为这些是你可能不想讨论的事情。但谈论金钱本身，我不认为我们应该感到羞耻。我们应该尽可能地消除羞耻感。
Every sort of kink that we would think is shameful in some way, whether that's a sexual fetish or an addiction. has money related to it in some way, right? If I'm addicted to a certain drug, I still have to pay for it. If I'm addicted to some sort of fetish, right, like people are paying for it in some sort of way. And so things that are just naturally shameful or that people feel shame, whether or not they should or not, right? I think those are things where you may not want to discuss that. But talking about money in general, I don't think that we should feel shame. We should get rid of shame as much as possible.
好吧，说到这里，我要感谢德拉罗萨博士今天接受我的采访。这真的非常有趣。我非常感谢你的见解。太棒了。非常感谢。你可以在美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）的六月刊上阅读更多关于德拉罗萨博士的研究。请访问我们的网站 www.apa.org 并查看《心理学对话》的相关链接。你也可以找到之前的剧集。
Well, on that note, I want to thank you, Dr. DeLerosa, for joining me today. This has been really interesting. I really appreciate your insights. Great. Thanks so much. You can read more about Dr. De La Rosa's work in the June issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to our website at www.org and look at www.combeckof Psychology.org and look at for the related links on this episode's page. You can also find previous episodes of
好的，说到这里，我要感谢德勒罗萨博士今天能来参加我的节目。这次谈话非常有趣，我非常感谢您的见解。太棒了。非常感谢。您可以在美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》六月刊中阅读更多关于德拉罗萨博士工作的内容。请访问我们的网站 www.apa.org，并在本期节目的页面上查找相关链接。您还可以找到往期的节目。
Speaking of Psychology at the same address, speakingof psychology.org, or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kemp. Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在speakingofpsychology.org，或者Apple、Spotify、YouTube以及您收听播客的任何平台找到《心理学谈话》。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作，我们的音频编辑是Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kemp Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。